hello everybody and welcome to another
monte carlo and python tutorial video
in this video we're going to pick up
where we left off with this day allen
bear strategy but now what we want to do
is we want to use the monte carlo
simulator
to find out at least
a couple variables so in this one we
want to do
wager size and wager count now again
wager size is in direct
relationship to your full amount of
funds
at least that's my argument so i don't
really see any reason
why we would want to make that as well a
variable
because really we're looking for a
percentage size of the total amount so
for now we're just going to do these
two variables so with that
let's go ahead and get started so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to have a wild true loop up here
and what i'm going to go ahead and do as
well is let's go up here
where all of our constants are let's go
ahead
and cut and paste those down here
so we'll just paste it right here i
guess
we don't need lower bust and higher
profit so i'm just going to move that up
here for now
we don't really care about that right
now sample size we want that that's
going to be a constant
starting funds that's also going to be a
constant but as i said we're going to
want to switch up
wager size and wager count and then
as well we want the return
that's going to be a contingent so we
want that to because
we're going to make a wild true loop so
i believe all of the rest of this
will be contained in the wild true so
let me make that wow
true loop so it makes more sense to you
guys
and so now we've got this so the only uh
constants up here are sample size and
starting funds
now the next thing that we want is
we're going to save trying to think
i guess that's really all we need for
now so then we come down here
wager size equals 100 and wager count
equals 100 000 or at least what we've
got here
um what we might want to do is switch
this up a little bit so
for example we could do wager size of a
hundred
um instead what we're going to do is
this so
comment both of those out and instead
wager size
is going to equal random.uniform
and let's do 1.0 to 100.00
and starting funds instead of 100 000
we're going to make that 10 000.
um that way 100 is a decent enough 100
is one percent
um and i i guess we could actually we
could go all the way up to a thousand
um that way we're trading up to 10
starting so wager size anything from one
to
you know from one one thousandth or
actually it's even
even smaller you guys get the point it's
a wide range of wager sizes
next a wager count
that's going to equal random dot uniform
and this is how many wagers are we
willing to perform let's do 1.0
and again i think we should allow up to
10 000 wagers anything between one and
ten thousand and really one is a
horrible number to start with let's do
ten
and ten thousand so we've got those down
now um so that's going to be our random
uh two random variables now we've got
return
that's always going to be the case d a
profits d a bus
all of that those stay the same
then we've got uh wow counter blah blah
blah
sounds good we come down here
and now what i want to go ahead and do
is we're going to set
um i guess we will use this but not
right this instant but we are going to
make an roi variable
so let's say roi equals
that and then we want to have like a
a line that we draw so we want to know
how large of a return on investment do
we care for
now the next problem that we have
is let's say we have a first of all
let's make this sample
smaller so what it's going to do is for
every random variable it's going to
test the sample so i'm going to make
this more like 10 000.
that other one was way too big that
would take a year to get
anything decent uh where was i
so down here and so we want to pick a
number now
i don't really know if i want to i hate
to hard code this really we should have
you know roi and then let's make a
total invested equals that
and roi should be some form of total
invested
right uh so what i think we'll do let's
run this a couple times to get a
some sort of a number and then we'll
make this a percentage so as long as roi
out of total invested is greater than x
that way
we can change the starting funds and all
of that um
dynamically and we won't have to like
pick a new number because obviously if
you do more wagers
you really are looking for a strategy
that makes more money and if you're
starting with more money
obviously you want to make more money so
we don't want to hard code it so with
that
uh we should be able to just run this so
let me save this
and run and hopefully we can run
and as it goes through the strategies we
hopefully
it's gonna spit out some stuff so this
one lost a lot of money and that was a
pretty big number
oh you know what let me uh let's break
this for now
uh so i can actually read this print
underscores
all right start again so anyway return
on in
intro let's see we got 300 000 but this
one was a huge number this was 2 million
21 million actually we lost 21 million
on that strategy
these guys are getting screwed right now
although these are randoms right we're
just randomly picking numbers just for
the record
so we did have a 21 million that's an 18
million so
so far we're seeing like 20 million
uh to beat
um i wish i knew maybe i'll go consult
that video and see what the actual
numbers were on the profitable version
of this strategy
so this was the typical allen bear
strategy right here so
total invested was 100 billion and we
made
865 million so 0.865 percent
so that's the number to be 0.865 so let
me close out of this
and so what we want to do is total
invested equals
this and then what we want to know is uh
i guess percent roi and that's going to
equal
roi out of total invested
um this in parentheses
times 100.00
now let's add one more print here just
to see if we got this right
percent roi and that's gonna equal
percent roi save and run it
and hopefully we can see a few examples
so
percent roi eight percent is what it's
claiming
it can't possibly be correct roi
returned eight percent
hold on let me pause this and check the
maths on that eight percenter
um here
okay just really wanted to check that
math that is correct so
the number to beat really is 0.8 and
this eight percentages is nice but just
keep in mind that we're only running for
10 000 samples okay so
that's very attractive and
we need to print out what the uh
interesting we should print out the uh
the wager size and the count as well i
would
would like to know what that was print
um wager size
i guess we'll make this typical
wager size and print
wager count read your
account and run it some more
lost money large wager size there wager
count
and i suppose as well what we could do
is we could say
wager size percentage
maybe well that's running let me do that
too so print
wager size percentage
and that would be wager size out of
starting funds
and then again times 100 so
we'll encase this bring that in
pretty sure you can have spaces there
but we'll find out
we don't want to find out wager size
percentage okay so now we got a
percentage
and we'll use that uh later on as well
so anyways run it again
did anybody make money on this one i
don't see anybody
oh we do have a three percent roi that's
pretty good anyway coming down here
uh this was a positive wager size was a
two percent wager
this was also a positive wager size was
seven
goodness
this was a positive waiter size 0.7 okay
so anyways you guys get the point now
what do we want to do i'll just leave
this running and then we'll look at it
in a second
but we do know that we need to be at
least
positive 0.86
uh percent roi right so what we want to
do now is come down here
and if percent
roi is greater than 0.865
uh percent then
show us the money right so we don't if
it's not greater than 0.865 percent roi
we really don't care wow look at this
one nine 49 roi
wager count six six six five thank
goodness it wasn't six six seven
uh wager size was pretty big too
anyway so we're seeing a bunch of uh
successful ones
and a bunch of unsuccessful ones
you know what else would be kind of cool
i have some ideas moving forward anyway
so what we're going to do now
is we've got this maybe we'd want to
make this number a little bit bigger
oh it looks like we're still returning
negatives
but would be interesting is we're
eventually going to plot this up
so i was just going to plot up the
positives but it probably would be a
good idea to plot up the negatives
too so the positives in green and the
negatives in red
and then where there's crossover that's
risk and then where there's not
crossover that's not written i think
that's what we'll end up doing
uh we're gonna have a pretty badass
looking plot by the end of this
so anyways um that's gonna conclude this
tutorial video at least where
at least right now what we're doing is
we're turning successful returns
basically
so um anything that has a percent roi on
average greater than
0.865 we return those variables so
anyways that's going to conclude this
video hopefully you guys enjoyed if
you've got any questions or comments
feel free to leave them below
as always thank you for watching thanks
for all the support and subscriptions
and until the next video